hello we're glad you've joined us for
this live webinar
accelerating gene editing research using
the power of flow cytometry
i am michelle ashton of labyrinths and
i'll be your moderator for today's event
today's educational web seminar is
presented by labyrinths
the leading scientific social networking
website and provider of virtual events
and webinars
advancing scientific collaboration and
learning
it's brought to you by thermo fisher
scientific
to learn more about our sponsor please
visit www.thermofisher.com
let's get started you can pose questions
to the speaker during the presentation
while they're fresh in your mind to do
so simply type them into the drop down
box located on the far
left of your screen labeled ask a
question and click on the send button
questions will be answered after the
presentation
to enlarge the slide window click on the
arrows at the top right hand corner of
the presentation window
if you experience technical problems
seeing or hearing a presentation
just click on the support tab found at
the top right of the presentation window
or report your problem by clicking on
the ask a question box
located on the far left of your screen
this is an educational webinar and thus
offers free continuing education credits
please click on the continuing education
credits tab
located at the top right of the
presentation window and follow the
process
of obtaining your credits i now present
today's speaker
natasha jacobson the product specialist
of flow cytometry instruments at thermo
fisher scientific
welcome natasha you may now begin your
presentation
hi thank you so much for joining so
today i'm going to discuss
um next level crispr gene editing with
flow cytometry and how you can use the
power of flow cytometry to streamline
and enhance
your crispr gene editing workflow so a
little more specifically of what we will
cover today we'll discuss some of the
traditional methods for analysis of gene
editing experiments
and then we'll talk about how flow
cytometry can be used for rapid high
throughput
analysis of these gene editing
experiments
we'll also discuss some of the unique
benefits of using flow cytometry and the
gene editing and cell engineering
workflow
and then also highlight and touch on
some of the additional applications in
the genome
editing workflow such as viral titering
viral transduction optimization
and fluorescent gene tagging
all right so let's start with discussing
what gene editing is
broadly and how it's done so gene
editing is the process whereby you
add remove or replace a piece of dna
and how is this done so the most widely
used method
and most efficient method currently is
using the crispr cas9 system
so the crispr cas9 system is an rna
guided dna
nuclear system that has two major
component
components to consider so one is the
cas9 protein
and this is the protein that actually
has the nuclear specifics the
the nucleus activity that allows you to
um
you know create a double stranded braid
and the
crispr rna is the target specific
portion this is how you actually target
exactly where you want your precise edit
to occur
and this happens through watson correct
standard
base pairing rules so as you can see you
have the target specific crispr rna
that's complex with the cas9
to target a specific portion of the
genomic loci
there are um you know there's really one
major thing
you need in order to target a specific
portion of the genome and that's a pam
so the pam is an ngg so it can be any
base followed by two g's
and um this is required for cast nine
combined
and you know any portion of the genome
that has this ngg
is now targetable by crispr um the
standard crispr length is 20 nucleotides
but that can vary
but that is the most commonly used
crispr length
and then there's also a tracer rna and
this combines
with the cas9 and we generally create a
fusion
and we collectively refer to this as a
guide rna
which is the target specific crispr rna
with the tracer rna
and these are the the two major
components that um that are required to
target anywhere on the genome that has a
pam
so why do we care about this i mean you
know really the opportunities
um for research and um you know even
cell and gene therapy
using crispr are they're really endless
that you can use this to create animal
disease models
tissue and disease modeling in vitro
this can also be used for stem cell
engineering
gene therapy applications and even for
agricultural studies to create you know
disease resistant transgenic plants
so let's get a little more into the
molecular pathway of gene modification
and you know how this occurs on the
molecular level
so you begin with your piece of double
stranded chromosomal dna
and from here when you add your cas9 and
guide rna complex
you create a gene-specific
double-stranded break
and at this point there are two pathways
that
the cell can go through it's the
cellular endogenous machinery
that repairs this double sprint stranded
break and one is non-homologous end
joining or
nhej in which the cleavage
is now uh the endogenous cellular
machinery um takes over and it either
adds and uh adds or deletes
portions of dna creating an indel
that refers to insertion or dilution and
this creates
a a knockout that's the overall goal and
that's really the the standard crispr
workflow
when you're just adding a guide rna and
a cast 9
your goal is generally to create a
knockout
um and one thing that's important to
note here is
this is not a controlled process right
this is
random within the cell uh you know how
many
bases get added or deleted at this time
the other pathway which is a little more
complicated is homology directed repair
and this is where you can create precise
edits and this is done very much in the
same way you still
are using a guide rna and the cas9
protein but in addition you also add a
donor template and this allows for a
precise
repair um based after your crisper
modification
and you can see through this little
drawing here you just require
a you know correctly designed donor
template with appropriate
appropriately designed homology arms and
then you can end up with a precise
modification
so this is very advantageous for um
if you want to let's say a mutate a
promoter or add a promoter
or even endogenously tag a gene or
addition
and um you know one thing that's you
know noteworthy here
is homology directed repair it it
happens
generally in a much less efficiency
a lower percentage it's a little harder
to
get a large number of cells that have
this precise modification
and that comes into play a little bit
later on some of the things we're going
to talk about
so let's you know take a you know a
little more of a deep dive and look
at the gene editing and cell engineering
workflow
so there are a lot of different reasons
to do gene editing and a lot of
different you know
experimental endpoints but most gene
editing experiments will follow
this um basic workflow which is to
design
deliver detect expand your clones and
validate
so during the design process you design
your guide rnas
order purifier synthesize these guide
rnas
and then the next step would be to
deliver so this would be to prepare
yourself
optimize your transfection efficiency
and we have a variety of different tools
available to do that whether you're
using neon transfection
if you're using the um our cas9 protein
lipofectamine crispr max there are a lot
of different
options including you know viral
delivery that's you know another option
for delivery as well
from here you need to detect um your
editing efficiency of your edited pool
so you know if you recall from the
previous slide i mentioned
that uh this the mutations that are
created
um using crispr cast nine are random
so you need to analyze the editing
efficiency
not all crispers are created equal right
and confirm the most appropriate guide
rna
to be used for your experiment from here
you now need to expand your clone so you
know depending on your
your application uh quite often
the end goal is to get a clonal
population
of an edited cell in which case you'll
need to
um you know go down to single clones and
screen and re-rack these clones
and then the final step of course will
be to validate
right to ensure that you have the
appropriate edit
and at the appropriate phenotype of
these edited cells and this is done
through genomic validation using ngs
sequencing genomic cleavage detection
sanger sequencing as well as off target
analysis
and functional validation and we'll go
through all of these in greater detail
as well
so you know what i'd like to highlight
here is this is really you know a
collection of tools and
the standard workflow and flow cytometry
um can really play a role and help
accelerate this
you know every step of the way for each
of these major
and and you know frankly laborious steps
through the gene editing workflow
so you can use flow cytometry to help
validate your guide rna design
you can use it to help optimize your
delivery
as well as quantify your editing
efficiency
and expedite the overall screening and
clonal isolation process
as well as get that functional
validation
of your edited clones at the end
and we have a variety of imaging tools
and a variety of instrumentation to help
with this as well
so i'm going to talk a little bit or
quite a bit rather about the
um a tune nxt flowcitometer a little bit
about
how that partners with evosalt imaging
in your functional analysis of your
edited cells
as well as some of our viability
reagents and
of course our antibodies for functional
validation
so let's take a little bit deeper dive
into the traditional methods
of editing efficiency analysis and this
overall workflow
so you can see here um the timeline
along the top
um i have about an average
representation here of 21 days and this
is from start to finish to create your
validated cell life some can take much
longer
and there are some cases you can go a
little bit quicker but that's a
an average so your first step is to
edit yourself by delivering your um you
know crispr cast iron complex to your
cell line or your primary cell
from here um you now have you know nhj
occurring and now you have an edited
pool and that's denoted here by the
different colors here so
you know each cell in theory can have a
different edit
at this point right um you have a a pool
of edited cells
and then the next step would then be to
isolate and expand
these edited cells using your you know
sorting or your limiting dilutions to
get
your single cell clones from here
there's you know another step of
screening and now you need to
consolidate these clones
into a 96 wall plate with um
and be able to you know functionally
analyze each of these you know
expanded clones and then the final step
would be to expand
validate and bank these cells so
through each of these steps there are a
lot of analysis stuff
right so you know this 21-day workflow
does not only require a lot of time um
you know a lot of cell culture in the
hood
but also a lot of additional wet lab
work
to you know analyze these clones on each
step of the way
so i'd like to talk a little bit about
some of the traditional methods of
editing analysis
so one would be uh the genomic cleavage
detection assay so this is a really
popular
gel based assay that can give you a you
know a quick
and semi-quantitative answer
as far as your gene editing experiment
and how efficient it was
so from this step uh you go through you
know lysing your cell palette
you uh design primers flanking the
region of interest surrounding your edit
and then you uh go through a denature
and re-anneal
and then go through an enzyme digestion
step that recognizes these
indoles that we discussed earlier and
then you can run a gel and analyze and
you can see here that this is you know
just done using band and psychometry
and you have a semi-quantitative answer
as far as you know
how what portion of your of your cells
are edited
based on that uncut versus cut band so
this is you know semi-quantitative
proportional analysis
so for the next level of accuracy
another option would be to use sanger
sequencing
um and sanger sequencing is also very
popular
for uh analyzing your editing efficiency
and it's
very quantitative and it goes through a
lot of the same steps so
you go through lysis um pcr as before
flanking your region of interest but
then you have to prepare a sequencing
reaction
using a big guy pcr and then a clean up
and then you actually need to run it
through the sequencing reaction
and then go through analysis and here i
have an example of two chromatograms
one of a control chromatogram
uncut as well as an edited sample
and you can see um just before about 210
base pairs you can see
where the cut site had occurred and you
can see that scrambled chromatic
chromatogram which is representative of
the edit in the indole
and this is run through a program i'm
using indel decomposition where we
integrate the area under the curve
to give you a nice quantitative estimate
of how edited what proportion of your
cells are edited in this pool
the next level of rigor here would be
using next-gen sequencing
very similar again as far as the steps
uh
you know you go through lysis pcr
amplification
it's a little more involved though with
ngs you need to
you know go through a few additional
steps such as adapter ligation
purification another pcr which is the
ngspcr reaction and purification
and then prepare the template and then
go through the ngs
and analysis and this again is
um you know it's it's still very useful
it
um is definitely an appropriate method
when you're doing your final
quantification
and you're off target analysis but this
is a lot of work
um all of these steps are above work and
in the meantime you know you're growing
the cells
as this is all happening taking your
lysates out
going into the wet lab and doing a lot
of additional
hands-on work and using a lot of
additional reagents to do this
so you know i'd like to propose and you
know suggest that
in many cases another appropriate method
to do this
would be to use glow cytometry so now
compare this workflow
um if if you're already growing your
cells
um in the cell culture really to analyze
your editing efficiency using flow
cytometry you just need a validated
antibody
in which case you just stain and wash
your cells and then you can run your
samples by flowcitometry
and analyze your data and this is you
know very high throughput
uh this is done you know using a 96 wall
plate
it doesn't require any additional
reagents except for some
you know flow cytometry buffer and an
antibody and you get a very nice
quantitative functional
knockdown of your gene editing
experiment
and so here i've just highlighted you
know an example of what this
data would look like and how you would
set up your experimental parameters so
in this case you know i'm looking at a
histogram
overlay plot of a cd47 knockdown
experiment so in this case i you know
designed a guide rna to target cd47
i had a validated cd47 antibody
conjugated to apc and you can see on the
right here
of this histogram this is an overlay
this is the
uh unedited cells versus the edited
cells
and you can see that you know shift to
the left showing
functional protein knockdown and then um
i have just a few examples
of the uh plate software
the plate analysis software on the
itunes nxt
where you can you know very quickly get
a nice pictorial layout
of the uh the knockdown efficiency and
as you can see you can test many
different parameters and you know look
at the effect each of these have on your
functional knockdown
and on the right i have an example of
you know what a gating tree would look
like
so the real message here is you know
you have your protocol completely set up
you know within your you know flow
cytometry analysis software within the
tune nxt
and you just run your plate and you have
everything you need essentially all your
analysis
is already done so
you know why use flow cytometry for gene
editing
so you know there's a lot of different
advantages um for
when to use flow cytometry and you know
when it can really you know augment and
expedite this workflow
so you know one benefit is you know it's
high throughput
right so you can use it to you know it's
a very high throughput method
to validate your guides and you know you
can collect a you know a 96 wall plate
in about 45 minutes none of the previous
methods mentioned
could give you an answer for you know 96
well plate and anywhere near that amount
of time
so it's much faster and which with much
less
waste another added benefit is it
actually gives you the functional
knockdown so
all of these other methods previously
described are you know looking at the
genomics
looking at the actual edit on the genome
which
as we know you know an edit does not
always confer knock down
so that's that's very important um
another huge advantage to using close
citometry is you're getting
single cell analysis so as i mentioned
previously when you edit a pool of cells
all of these cells theoretically can
have different edits
um when you're using flow cytometry
you're actually
looking at a single cell knockdown and
you can
you know use that to know how many of
your single cells are actually
functionally knocked down
and really the only way to do this using
these other methods would be to
go to clonal isolation which if you
recall is about
three weeks and a lot of work down the
road
another thing that close cytometry can
give you
information it can give you that these
other methods can't is really guide rna
multiplexing analysis
so you can actually look at as i
mentioned single cell analysis
but you can look at multiple genes being
knocked down
um in a single cell right simultaneously
and you can do this without clonal
isolation
another really important application of
low cytometry is being able to
target and look at these gene
interactions being able to analyze these
functional gene networks like synthetic
lethality and synergistic effects um
you know we know that you know these
gene networks exist in highly redundant
pathways
and you know sometimes you may need to
knock down
a few genes to get the desired phenotype
that you require
and you know flow cytometry allows you
to do that and adds that power to your
research
um another very important um reason
to use less optometry in your gene
editing experiment
is you know we're using cell biology
right we need to be able to look at the
viability
of ourselves look at the proliferation
you know see if
other effects to the overall cell growth
and cell phenotype after edit so that
adds a lot of value as well
so i'm going to go through you know one
application and this would be using um
you know gene editing in the pbmc
workflow
using crispr casino tuna nxt
so you know the basic workflow here
would be to you know go through our
t-cell isolation and activation
um as you see we have you know dyna
beads kits for that
and then go through t-cell editing the
next step and you know and i have a few
representative tools and products um
listed here on the right that can you
know help this process along the way
like the neon transfection system
our true cut cas9 protein as well as our
synthetic guide rnas from here you can
then do the functional knockout analysis
um using our ebiosciences antibodies and
the a-tune nxt
and then you can also use the
fluorescent viability dies to give you
more information
about your edited cells um in the end
right for the overall cell phenotype
and then of course you know for any
validated cell line and
in any gene editing workflow at some
point
um you know genomic analysis is
important as well
right and we have all of those tools as
well you know from our
genomic cleavage detection kit to give
kind of a
a quick and straightforward um you know
answer that's semi-quantitative
and then of course we also have sanger
sequencing and next-gen sequencing as
well
so here i'd just like to you know kind
of take you through this workflow a
little bit and give you an example of
you know what the data looks like so up
on the top i have you know the workflow
stated out
um again as well and you know you can
see
that within you know it's a 48-hour
process
to you know validate your guide rna and
look at your knockdown efficiency using
flow cytometry
so in this case this is a guide rna
targeting the um
pcr in pbmcs and this is conjugated to
pe
and as you can see on the bottom left we
have the scatter plot
um with you know fluorescence on the
x-axis and then scatter on the y-axis
and you can see that the cells that are
untransfected
untreated are you know 92 tcr positive
and then we have two different um guide
rnas targeting the
track in prbc locus that were used
using electroporation and cas9 rnp and
you can
see you know the statistics right here
on the plot you can see that we have you
know 97.8
knockdown and 92.5 knock down
respectively for each of these and you
know this is an
answer uh that is you know attainable
within you know 48 hours
of your experiment and you know without
any additional processing steps
and then you know additionally you know
looking at uh
you know another piece of data within
this experimental workflow is it
correlates very very nicely to editing
efficiency by ngs
and you know in a lot of ways it gives a
little more information
and these two are used as pairs quite
frequently
right you know looking at how efficient
um you were able to edit the genome
versus how efficiently you were able to
knock down
the functional protein and um you can
see that here as well
and you know this is um really the
first step on kind of going going back
one of the first steps of any
genome editing experiment is to validate
your guide rna designs and
pick the best one and we rarely just
design
one guide rna right standard most people
choose about three
right and then decide to move forward
with the best one from there
so you know in the case of using flow
cytometry you can have your
answer in 48 hours and then know which
is your most appropriate guide
to move forward with very very quickly
so really the the next um you know huge
advantage to using flow cytometry here
and and not just an advantage but
it's you know unattainable by um by
other means
um by standard means and and that's the
ability to look at
multiplex editing so um as i mentioned
before
you know in in a lot of cases when
you're doing cell engineering
and you know when you're when you're
trying to do cell therapy studies
there may be several genes that you need
to edit
in order to get the desired phenotype in
in order to get
the you know desired cell line that you
require
and um flow cytometry allows you to
you know interrogate these cells and do
single cell analysis
for looking at multiplex knockdown so
um if you remember previously you have a
pool right if you're using
ngs or sanger sequencing or genomic
cleavage detection
you need to move down to single cells
right
and then you can um you know be able to
to know for certain that it has all
three targets knocked out
in the case of low cytometry i can just
add all three antibodies at the same
time
right um that of course these are
pre-validated antibodies
and i can actually know what
what proportion of my transfected pool
has actually been edited for all three
targets
at the same time and that is um very
useful
and very powerful and then in addition
to that
another thing worth mentioning is you
know from
the next step here is if i was to do gcd
sanger ngs i now need to design
three different experiments three
different prime primer sets
to amplify each locus right
so you know an n of one experiment
immediately becomes nf3
right and you know that compounds over
time depending on how many edits you
want to make
but in the case of flow cytometry you
can see this
this graph here this is actually just
um you know one well
nf3 right where i've edited three
different targets so b2m
pd1 and the track locus and i've
analyzed them via
ngs gcd sanger flow cytometry and
viability
and you can see that they they correlate
very very nicely
on the the sanger the ngs and the flow
cytometry um you know
are you know very predictive with one
another um and then i also got this
additional uh you know viability uh
measurement as well
and um just just remember here with this
was n of three so with glow cytometry i
just had to put the plate in and run
three wells
to get the equivalent data here that's
represented in this graph via ngs
gcd and sanger i actually had to
multiply that by three again and look at
each of these targets
um individually meaning i'm really just
getting an
estimate here of what i think my triple
knockout efficiency would be
based on you know statistical analysis
but with flow i actually have an exact
answer i know
you know approximately 54 of myself
successfully have all three of those
efforts
and that is very very helpful as well
for you doing further studies down the
line on viability
as well as knowing how many clones i
need to play it out to get the cell line
that i desire
so another advantage um and another
level of power that flow cytometry has
is you know you can really look at you
know gene expression over time
so you know making an edit to the genome
uh you know isn't going to change as
much as expression can't
right so so we know that you know when
you're looking at pbmcs for example
there's a lot of differences between
donors
and you know again you know these cells
exist and you know these genes are
interacting with
one another in complicated gene networks
and you know
expression can definitely change over
time
so fluid cytometry can give you that
additional
you know piece of information about what
the actual expression levels
of these proteins are over time and
again
you know if they recover so you know on
the right
i just wanted to know give you a
snapshot of some of the things that you
can encounter in a gene editing
experiment so
this is the the previous data set right
three different genes
um you know being multiplexed to edit at
the same time
and i looked at these both you know
three days post edit and seven days post
edit
and um this is a heat map set to a pd1
expression
so you know if you can look at the you
know the upper right hand corner
where i've you know drawn a box around
that port portion of the plate
so this is a you know a single knockout
so you know seven days post editing my
pd1
is still knocked down effectively
however
if you look at in the bottom left of the
seven days post edit plate um
you know outlined there in red my pd-1
expression recovered
over time um and that's really important
because
when i ran my my ngs
when i did my finger sequencing the same
proportion of my cells is still knocked
out
the the gene's still been edited but it
wasn't completely knocked out right
so now it can still be influenced by
other genes that it's interacting with
and you know this is a well-documented
uh issue is
b2m has been implicated as being an
issue for pd-1 resistant or pd-1
treatment-resistant tumors so you know
fluid cytometry
can give you that extra level of power
to look at your gene interactions
and you know this wasn't something um
for example that you know i was
anticipating
uh or looking for and you know this was
you know really important to know
uh that you know my expression was not
going to exactly correlate with my
knockdown
because of this gene interaction so
flow cytometry allows us to have a more
comprehensive analysis
of gene knockdown and you know really
elucidate these gene interactions that
you you wouldn't be able to detect
easily using other methods and then
you know here's just a another example
of a you know a really straightforward
panel um
it was a little more straightforward
because these genes did not interact
with each other
um in the same way that b2m and pd1 did
and um you can see again here's you know
just an example
of you know the data you get from flow
cytometry you can see that overlays on
the top
the unedited versus edited populations
um on this uh overlay plot which is all
you know
just you know already in the um the
attuned software
and then you can look at these bivariate
plots and you know look at your
different populations and
you know the flow cytometry also allows
a lot of nice visual tools like um you
know hyperlog plots where you can
you know really look at your expression
levels and your populations and help you
know
help to tease out and find that data
so you know so that's you know moving
forward to you know
another level of power that flow
cytometry allows for your gene editing
cell engineering
experiments and that is it gives you an
option to do
viability studies as well and that's
very very
important right um you know you're doing
gene editing but in the
end you know you're you're looking at
yourself you're looking at your
self-help
you're looking at you know their ability
to proliferate their viability
um over time additionally you know if
you're optimizing gene editing
experiments or say you know the goal is
to create gene editing tools you know i
mean toxicity is very very important
so you know here's another example of uh
using flow cytometry to get that
additional level of data so here i've
used
just you know two dyes um cytox red
and um calcium am one is a membrane
permeability dye so cytox red will enter
the cells if the membrane has been
compromised
and then the calcium am is a uh
is a vitality dye so you know you can
see that there are you know a couple
different populations here
right you have your um the majority of
your population are going to be your
viable cells up here they're calcium am
positive and cytokines red negative but
then you also have you know two
other populations um you also are going
to have some where their
you know membrane is compromised but yet
they're still
you know showing vitality and then you
also see the ones that
uh have your um that are cytox red
positive and calcium am negative so
those are you know truly your
your dead cells and you know as you can
see here
um you know you have a plate map you
know right off the bat that gives you a
visual representation
of this viability of yourself and then
you know all the necessary
statistics as well to look at your your
cell viability based on different
conditions
so it's a really nice way to um you know
optimize your dosage for your gene
editing experiments
as well as your transaction conditions
you know your
your payload and you know your um
electroporation protocol if applicable
you know all that stuff is you know not
arbitrary and can be very time consuming
so it's nice to have this um
accurate readout and again remember it's
you're still in the same plate
you don't need to create a duplicate
plate for another assay you know all
this data
um you you can get at once
um so you know and along the same lines
you know flow cytometry gives you
additional data as well it gives your
cal
um count and concentration data which is
really nice and
the attune is uniquely uh positioned for
this because the etunemix people of
cytometer is a syringe driven system
so you can use the attune to get precise
volumetric counts without the need of
counting beads
which is you know really great and that
not only does it give you that count and
concentration data
but um you know if your end r
if your end goal is to get a clonal
population
of cells then at some point you're going
to probably go through limiting
dilutions
right and you're going to you know plate
your you know your 0.8 cells per ml or
0.5 cells per ml whatever your
um you know general um protocol is
and you know so you can analyze your
your data on
the attune flow cytometer and then
immediately have a count
and you know don't need to go through
another counting step and then go
directly to your plate
and you know another really nice thing
about having this count data is you know
for optimizing your transaction
right um you know every single method
including neon right you know the zap of
the neon
is gonna kill some of your cells as you
go and
you know that is definitely uh you know
a part of the workflow
that is you know very time consuming and
necessary
right so you know you can see quickly
here that you know i can
you know use flow cytometry to also
optimize my neon conditions
and you know see how many cells i'm
going to need to start with
you know in order to move forward
because i get that accurate count
so you know just along those same lines
you know flow cytometry can really
simplify and expedite this limiting
dilution calculation as i talked before
so you know your your standard um
process would be to you know edit your
cells
and then you know light your sample and
evaluate via genomic cleavage or
sequencing
count your cells and plate by limiting
delusions
right and you know you can see i have a
you know a big stack of plates there um
that is pretty standard for one cell
line um depending
on the um the cells that you're using
maybe 10 to 20 plates just to get one
cell line right
um and these are you know this is media
this is hands
you know you have to you know take care
of these over time space in your
incubator
um you know or you know you can use the
attune nxt
um get an accurate count even use the
attune nxt
sample recovery feature right and you
know
use this multi-parameter analysis as
well um to get immediate and accurate
results
um in one single step and you know what
what i mean here that was kind of a lot
um is you know if i'm trying to get
a single cell um
a clonal population that has three
knockouts right if i use theotune and i
and i use
uh you know my my three antibodies and i
know that i'm 55
triple knockout and i also have my count
i've already done all my work i know you
know
to a high level of statistical
certainty how many plates i'm going to
have to plate out
to get that and there's there's really
no other way to um
to get that data and really get it that
quickly and
just the the amount of time that that
can save
and you know with that additional level
of accuracy
is just staggering and then additionally
adding things like viability parameters
as well you know that
gives you an even better estimate of you
know how many
plates you'll need to play it out to get
your desired clone
so um you know along the same lines that
switching gears a little bit
um you know i've talked a little bit
about guide rna validation and
optimization
so you know a lot of times where you
know we're looking at the overall
you know knockdown but sometimes you
know we're trying to create
uh you know nice assays to you know to
measure our efficiency
you know let's say if we're trying to
you know optimize a guide rna design or
a certain type of
guide rna purification or what have you
um you know in some cases you may not
need to go through sequencing you may
not need to
end up with a clonal population but
let's say you're just trying to optimize
your um experimental parameters and and
see how well it works so
here's an example with fluorescent
proteins and you know i just heard the
example here on the left because you
know flow cytometry can definitely you
know work
very much hand in hand with cell imaging
so
this is an nf kappa b sensor cell line
that has a gfp fused to ns kappa b
and this is a nuclear translocation
assay so
you know when stimulated with tanf alpha
right it
um the nf kappa b will be in the nucleus
otherwise you'll see it concentrated in
the cytoplasm
and i you know have a schematic of that
you know that pathway there on the left
but you know i also used this cell line
to um you know this stably expressing
gfp
to optimize my guide rna conditions
right
and you know optimize um some aspects of
my delivery as well
and you know you can see that you know i
just have my overlay with
showing the gfp knockdown and that's
gonna you know be
my overall metric for my efficiency
and then i i also have my you know my
plate map down below
and you know now i have my percent gfp
knockdown for a lot of different
conditions that i tried when i was
preparing
different types of guide rna so i
blinded those a little bit
the conditions are just denoted by you
know a b c and d
as well as ivt and then i have my my
various controls as well like my
untransfected control and my um guide
rna
that's not targeting any area in the
genome control
and you know as you can see i have my
you know my gfp knockdown um this
normalized mf3
as well as you know my comparison to my
genomic cleavage assay
as well as my viability measurement and
you know
in this case you know i was able to
analyze a 96 wall plate
by just really not having to do
any additional processing i just needed
to lift myself from the plate and put
them in the flow cytometer
and you know press go and you know now i
have
all of this data that would have taken
me the better part of a week
and you know a lot of different reagents
and labware and hands-on time
to be able to get this by other methods
so you know now i'd like to show you
another application so i talked a little
bit
about you know gene tagging and i've
really focused on you know knockdown but
you know another application of gene
editing is being able to tag a gene
um you know once you tag a gene there's
a lot of different things you can do
with that information
um you know from a gene editing
standpoint let's say you're trying to
look at gene modulation
right and so you know you want to create
a gene tag
so we have a really nice kit it's a true
tag
donor dna kit for gene tagging and you
can use this for gene modulation
analysis
and you know of course since we're
tagging with a fluorescent protein
you could see that you know it's really
valuable and you know one method
to you know analyze these types of
experi these types of experiments is
using flow cytometry
so we have uh you know a couple
different options for this gene tagging
kit we have a gfp
or an rfp tag or a luciferase reporter
and you can tag either the c or
n terminal of a gene and
i'll move to the next slide and this
gives you you know a nice little
schematic
of you know how this is prepared and and
how this workflow
um works so um we provide you know
everything needed
to um design this experiment
appropriately
and you know you can knock in the um tag
here and this is using
hdr which i talked about before because
we're doing a you know a precise
modification
to a gene and um additionally in
addition to adding the fluorescent
marker
um you can also add a resistance marker
um which can allow you to then use
you know antibiotic selection on your
cells as well
and then there are lox p sites so you
can cleanly you know use cream
recombinaes
to you know remove that resistance
marker at the end
and um this is a really nice way um to
tag a gene
and to look at homologous recombination
and look at you know potential gene
modulation study so
you know here's a another example of the
workflow and um how
imaging uh works well um with flow
cytometry together
and you can see that you know within you
know day one you've prepared your
donor dna um days three and four you can
start to see
um the the tag um being expressed
and then at daytime you can see that you
know we're 99.9
99.5 um gfp positive
right after applying selection
so and then here's also just you know
some nice pictures
um you know looking at uh the
you know beta actin uh tag uh
using uh you know our gfp kit
um and you can see these are just really
nice pictures generated from our
our evas microscope fluorescent
microscope
so you know i'd just like to show you
some you know application data so you
know umbilical cord blood is you know
very relevant and notoriously difficult
to edit
right and it's you know very important
for um
a variety of therapeutic applications
and you know here's an example of using
the true tag
right um to be able to
tag right this gene and you can see that
you know we
looked at you know a few different
markers
and you know within five to seven days
uh we were able to you know affect these
cells for
um using the colony forming count
as well as the atuna nxt to look at the
different
differentiation differentiates and
capacity
of these gfp positive cells and um you
know note we're also able to look at the
different doses and get a really nice
dose response of our editing experiment
as well as measured by
gfp positive cells and you know these
were also
analyzed you know to ensure that they
were still cd 34 positive and cd90
positive you know after
adding the true tag and that's just you
know another
um level of rigor and you know something
that i touched on before and wanted to
add you know again is you know
as you're doing these gene editing
experiments flow cytometry
also gives you this you know ability to
look at a lot of different parameters of
interest at the same time
to ensure that your cells are not being
affected
in some other way that you did not plan
on
and also ensure that you still have
functional capacity
this is also you know of course you know
very relevant for you know ipsb
studies being able to use flow cytometry
to to verify that your cells are you
know still
expressing the appropriate pluripotency
markers um
you know at the end of your experiment
and you know and then from uh you know
an optimization standpoint you know as i
as i mentioned before you know some of
these you know primary cells are
very difficult to edit even harder to
edit using
hdr and you know really need to go
through the neon process
and need to be optimized which is not
arbitrary so
you know here's an example of you know
using flow cytometry
to get you know some very nice data with
statistical power
showing um the appropriate buffer right
to be used
um for this um hdr experiment using neon
so you know it can really be used
through every step of the workflow from
beginning to end
and you know save a lot of time
um an additional application of flow
cytometry would be you know
using um you know using flow cytometry
to optimize
um you know your viral workflow
so you know if you're
running a screening application or need
to optimize your moi
there are a lot of different ways that
flow cytometry can come in handy
here as well so you know just for you
know one example
you know i i i have here a schematic of
our you know our lentiviral library
so you know one of our products is we
have a library that targets the entire
genome
um and you know the with the the goal to
be
to you know assay um using these
libraries you know knockout screens
uh and you know one application
um where we use flow cytometry and
developing this was
to use solid cytometry not only just for
our um
you know our viral titering but also to
optimize our
moi so you know which is you know varies
greatly between different cell lines and
you know depending on your workflow and
what you're trying to do
so here's an example of uh you know
ht1080 cells you know infected with you
know viral particles
um that had a gfp in the backbone as
well
and you know here's an example of using
viral titering so
you know as you can imagine um you know
creating
a you know a library targeting an entire
human genome drugable genome about 20
000 genes that is a
lot of viral production and a lot of
viral titering
and a lot of steps and a lot of things
frankly that can go wrong along the way
so um you know we used flow cytometry
regularly
and used those gfp lengthy control
particles because we were producing our
virus and we used that as a sentinel
as we were tightering hundreds and
hundreds of plates
via p24 via antibiotic selection
you know crystal violet staining we used
the
um gfp tittering uh as a as a sentinel
that was you know so much faster and you
know saved us you know
countless hours and you know really
money
right in order to um you know check any
plates
um doing a qa check before we move to
the next step
of viral production which is very handy
so you can really you know get creative
and use it in a lot of different ways
um another way i would use flow
cytometry is
uh you know and this is you know our
standard recommendation for customers
who purchase a library
is to use these lentiviral control
particles to first
optimize their moi and you know optimize
not just their moi but their general
viral transduction protocols for
for their their cell line of interest um
you know how many days they want to
select um how much cas9
virus they want to add versus how much
of the guide rna virus they want to add
and you know at what time point you want
to run the assay
so again you know flow cytometry was a
very high throughput way
to you know check for functionality of
these different targets right and you
can see
you're familiar at this point with the
you know the knockdown plots
but also look at the appropriate days of
selection
that um you know were best for this cell
line
um to get you know your maximum
knockout efficiency while also you know
minimizing the time that you uh need to
keep these cells growing
over time and and moving forward so
um so this is you know optimizing viral
transduction using flow cytometry
is um you know something that we would
use all the time
as well um here's just a another example
of flow cytometry used in conjunction
with imaging
um you know here's an example of you
know using politometry to validate
functional knockdown of the centromeric
protein um insep
and you can see the multinucleated cells
right versus that have been uh that have
been treated with guide rna versus the
cas9 only control um analyzed by flow
cytometry
and then you can also see visually these
cells under the microscope and you can
see
um you know you can validate this
experiment with your eyes as well
so you know now that i've talked about
you know flow cytometry and the
you know advantages to using
felicitometry and gene ebony kind of
like to
you know do you know compare and
contrast some of the methods and and
some of the things you can get from flow
some of the things that you can't
and you know where it can uh really
really help and where it adds the most
benefit
so you know as far as hands-on time it
is you know
a clear winner compared to these other
methods as far as how quickly
you can get your um functional knockout
data
um you know all of these methods require
an instrument
right um you know there are different
instruments as far as the level of
maintenance
um that is required to do so as well as
the availability of the standard lab
so you know not everybody has a 3730 or
you know an ion chef um probably
most labs will have you know uv and be
able to image a gel
so that's one thing that's handy about
about the gcd kit
and as far as consumables cost low
cytometry is really the clear winner as
well
um you know as i mentioned before you
don't require any additional
um consumables necessarily i mean of
course it depends on your experiment but
if you're doing you know knock-down
analysis you just require an antibody
if you're if you have a fluorescent
protein based system you may not even
require that
um and again you know this is you know
not requiring a lot of different plate
transfers a lot of pipette tips and
everything else
you can just put yourself ultra plate
you know once you've
you know appropriately prepared it in
the flow cytometer
um you know as far as automated data
analysis you know sanger can be quite
automated as well
ngs is less automated um
but it still can be automated um genomic
cleavage detection not so much
um that would be um you know very time
consuming to
analyze you know at you know 896 well
plates is in the example here
um turnaround time very quick your
answer is immediate
um it is very amenable to
automation as well and some of the other
methods are as well
but i would say it is the most amenable
to automation
as far as environmental impact um flow
cytometry is very nice because again
you're just it's just the reagents on
the consumables to run the
instrument as well as you know what
other antibody you may need or whatever
you know plates you require
to um to analyze you you don't need a
lot extra
as you can see i have a picture here
down below just highlighting the amount
of waste
that uh that is required to process
and you know get these answers using
sanger ngs and gcd
you know flow cytometry there's no
picture there because it doesn't require
anything additional
once you move that plate out of the
tissue culture hood
um as far as accuracy and precision
precision it's very high max throughput
per day
it is definitely the highest sanger
would be the close second but then again
this is assuming you have a 3730 that
can run 16 plates overnight not everyone
has that
flow cytometry will also allow you to do
knock-in analysis
um the others will not it also gives you
that additional
metrics of cell function and viability
now you know one thing that you know
flow cytometry will not give you the
detailed indulge spectrum and
of course if you're creating a stable
cell line you will need to at one point
you know validate that
um cell line by other methods at some
point so
you know really you know that the
take-home here is you know flow
cytometry is not just efficient but it's
very cost effective from both you know a
labor and consumable standpoint and it
is very clean and safe you're not
running gels
you know you're not um generating a ton
of plastics to run these experiments
which
is always nice wherever we can as
scientists right
so i'd like to just you know show you
one picture
you know of an example of the attune so
you know really you know genome editing
is one of the most important things is
faster right um you know to be able to
you know
get our answers faster and you know get
these um studies done more quickly
um of course with the level of rigor we
need for for our analysis
as well and you know flow cytometry
really enables that so
here i have you know the attune
highlighted you know you can
analyze up to 14 parameters it's very
small you can even put it in a hose it's
very robust and clog resistant
um from a fluidic standpoint it is you
know very straightforward and does not
you know use a lot of fluidics and then
it's you know totally automatable
right you can you know use a you know
orbiter which can move the plates in and
out
run plates overnight and then we have
our new sidekick max auto sampler
which can run plates very quickly before
i talked about 45 minutes well that's
now about cut in half it's about 23
minutes
to analyze a 96 wall plate we also have
external fluidics and all kinds of extra
automation
capabilities in order to um you know
completely automate this workflow
so in summary you know flow cytometry
provides a rapid and robust functional
knockdown validation of edited cells
it accelerates it it speeds it up right
so it's truly high throughput
and automated as a workflow solution
it advances cell engineering studies as
well because it you know allows us to do
those things
we talked about before as far as you
know gene interactions
um single cell analysis of multiplex
multiplexed experiments and you know
again it's you know
efficient cost effective and
environmentally friendly which is you
know really a nice added benefit
and you know the the etude nxt in
particular
um with the psychic masks is fast right
so you know it gives you know it's just
the perfect complement
for the workflow and that it's very fast
and very user friendly
so you know i'd like to just you know
highlight to you i encourage you to
visit our website and you know learn
more about some of the resources we have
we have a lot of
low cytometry learning resources online
learning centers we have our flow
cytometry capabilities guide
we have our panel builder as well as our
antibody search tools
and you know our molecular probes
handbooks and a variety of educational
webinars and you know virtual
entertainment
that i encourage you to take a look at
so with that um i will take any
questions um thank you so much for your
time and attention
and yeah please let me know if you have
any questions and
you can also feel free to follow up with
me anytime using the
contact information on the invite
thank you
thank you natasha for your presentation
we will now start the q
a session of the webinar a quick
reminder for our audience on how to
submit questions
simply type them into the drop down box
located on the far
left of your screen labeled ask a
question and click on the send button
natasha will answer as many questions as
time permits
okay let's get started our first
question is
what is the main value that flow
cytometry adds to crispr
experiments that other methods don't
offer
um well you know really that would be
the multi-parameter analysis
um which would be the short answer i
mean you know it's it's great advantage
i talked a lot about
speed um and efficiency but the ability
to get that multi-parameter
analysis looking at multiple genes
multiple functional
knockdowns at the same time would i
think be that the greatest benefit
conferred by solicitometry that you know
isn't accessible by other methods
great thank you okay your next question
is
are there other applications or
advantages
to using flow cytometry in the gene
editing workflow
that weren't mentioned in this
presentation
um well you know there's a few tools and
a few things i didn't have time to get
to
so um you know one really great
advantage to using fluid cytometry is um
we have something called the prime flow
assay which i you know really recommend
you
you know look at and get more
information about and that's an ability
to actually
look at your mrna and your gene
expression
simultaneously at the single cell level
now what is the main advantage of using
the etune nxt
flow cytometer in the cell engineering
workflow
well the attune is uniquely positioned i
think because it is um you know
so compact it has a you know a small
footprint
you can you know put it in your you know
hood fits easily
in your bench top it's very accessible
and easy to use
but i think that you know from a
functional standpoint it's just
it's very very fast um it's about 10
times
faster than other cytometers
and you know that's a huge advantage
when you're trying to process
you know dozens of plates and high
throughput analysis as you're often
doing with chain editing experiments
thank you it looks like we have time for
one more question
let's go with this one where do you
think the greatest upcoming potential
synergy between
flow cytometry and cell engineering
using crispr
so that's a really good question so i
think um
you know one thing that i'm personally
really excited to see
is you know using flow cytometry and
gene editing for gene interaction
studies so
um this field has never been more
accessible because you know
with advent of crispr it really allowed
us to create
um these you know easy and you know high
efficiency knockouts which is you know
really opened up the field of gene
interaction studies
so i think you know looking at these
multi-gene networks and looking at these
synergistic effects between genes
um is you know going it's a burgeoning
field
and then the ability you know no other
methodology can really analyze that like
flow cytometry can
as far as looking at all the different
parameters and getting that level of
statistical power
as as you're doing it so yeah i think
gene interaction studies
um is is going to be you know very
interesting
as you know within the next few years
and crispr and polycytometry together
great thank you i would like to once
again thank natasha for her presentation
and before we go i'd like to thank the
audience for joining us today and for
their questions
as a reminder any questions we did not
have time for today will be addressed by
the speaker via the contact information
you provided at the time of registration
we would like to thank labberts and our
sponsor thermo fisher scientific for
underwriting today's educational webcast
this webcast can be viewed on demand lab
routes will alert you via email when
it's available for replay
we encourage you to share that email
with your colleagues who may have missed
today's event
until next time goodbye